when do you start writing everyday I'm
right so I have basically the same
pattern when I'm writing sometimes if
I'm doing if I'm in production or it'll
it'll change but if I'm just in a
writing phase which is my favorite to be
honest with you because I love my
schedule as a writer is I wake up I go
somewhere have breakfast and usually
I'll go somewhere I can have breakfast
and write and then I'll open my computer
so now it's around 10:30 ish and then I
return emails for about an hour hour and
a half and then I start writing and then
I write for about three to four hours
straight and then I'm done and that is
basically my process and sometimes it
takes me two hours to get started and
then when I get to that two hour mark
and I haven't started that's when
self-loathing comes in so then I do get
started but usually I can get going in
about an hour to an hour and a half it's
a computer that has it's hooked up to
the Internet so yeah yeah I'm definitely
stay on the internet because I'm looking
things up all the time is I'm writing
sometimes it's just random things I'm
looking for a synonym for something and
I'll just type go-to synonym and type in
a word and some synonyms will pop up and
so it can be as simple as that so it's
not a distraction it's no not on the
whole I mean it can be a little bit but
but it works for me and so but that's
that's my schedule and what's the
longest writing day you've ever had oh I
don't like to write once I'm get tired
because then I just lose my focus and
the writing is on is good so but yeah
yeah I was for the first two seasons on
Empire I wrote a lot of the show and so
those would turn into sometimes a long
days and where you're writing you're
rewriting an episode and you're doing a
lot of work so sometimes just ten hours
and I don't like it at all and I don't
think the work I think the work suffers
for it so you think you're better at the
three to four hours yeah that's why I do
it I mean it's literally as soon as I
start to lose my focus then just stop
and I don't have writer's block I don't
it's not a very dramatic thing there's
no inspiration I don't wait
for inspiration I say inspiration is for
amateurs amateurs get inspired
professionals just go do it and and it's
not even very dramatic anymore I mean I
just go and I know I'm gonna do it I
mean I know I'm gonna get stuff done and
it's very productive to be honest with
you I find that that I get a lot of
writing done because I don't make a big
deal about it I don't it's not this big
dramatic thing for me I just show up and
then I just get going and like I said it
takes sometimes an hour an hour and a
half to actually get started
occasionally two hours and then we and
then I just start going and I try to be
non-judgmental of it and I don't sit
there and question it or think that I'm
not talented or I just try and do it and
then and then there's a phase when you
have to edit it and go through it and
that can be more you know that's a more
critical part of your brain but I do my
best to not beat myself up about it and
if I don't like something I just change
it I just keep working on it and working
on it and not turn it into some big
melodramatic artists struggle I don't I
don't view it that way at all I will say
one thing that I think could be very
interesting to people that are writers
is is what I do is I outline a script
very meticulously and my outlines are
about 25 pages to 30 pages long and then
when I go to write the actual first
draft I will not read one word of what
I've written until I've written the
whole script so for my first pass on a
screenplay I start from the beginning
and then I just go and I go all the way
through until I'm done without having
read one word of it and it takes about
three weeks so in three weeks I've
written a whole draft and it's a lot of
fun because there is no judgment
whatsoever I'm just writing straight
through and then I go through and very
meticulously work through the scenes and
that takes two to three weeks and then
in six weeks I have a draft but it's
really two drafts because I've done one
straight through and then one this sort
of meticulous work through and I will
say that the second phase of it the
meticulous
work through phase is the least
enjoyable part of the whole process
because it's the most critical we're
just for a couple weeks it's just I have
to work through these scenes and and and
then but I just do it and then after
that I have a draft to work off of and
then there's many drafts after that but
it's it's I have this nice foundation so
going back to what you said about not
making a big deal about waiting for
inspiration
yeah was it always that way for you I
know this was over many years of
figuring this out and for the first
several years I was writing I was deep
in my acting career and writing was more
therapeutic to get my mind off of the
very painful trials and tribulations of
an acting career because it's very
difficult and you get rejected a lot and
all the cliches are absolutely true and
then but I was serious about it but it
was you know I think it just took a
while I'm realizing that beating
yourself up and I have no talent or this
is terrible or I oh I'll work with a
writer and they'll say oh that was
I said don't don't worry about it don't
worry about if it's good or bad just
let's just take a look at it and see
what what could be improved there's no
reason to be so caustic and hostile
about the material it's just words on
its screen you can change them it's just
just changing so that's very much
something that guides me and in my work
you